For any fisherman, it's the moment of uncertainty.
Boat owner Musa Foon keeps a watchful eye
on the net as it comes in.
Today, to his joy, the River Gambia has provided.
"I really like this job, because I am jobless
before this brigade come.
So now I am fully engaged.
I am a fulltime fisherman now.
I am very happy doing it.
And I really like it."
Musa Foon got the money to buy his fishing
boat from the IOM, the International Organization
for Migration, which has been trying to boost
the local economy in eastern Gambia.
It's given the 26-year-old his first steady
job since leaving school.
The European Union is also pumping money into
the region, with its 11-million-euro Gambia
Youth Empowerment Scheme.
Musa Foon says are definite signs of improvement.
With a new government in power and more development
aid, he hopes his home region will benefit.
"With this system, I believe things are changing.
The EU just pumping money for the youths to
do something with their lives.
That's a good start."
The development programs of the IOM and EU
are part of a broader strategy -- to stem
the flow of migrants trying to reach Europe.
Last year alone more than 12-thousand Gambians
crossed the Mediterranean.
That from a country of less than two million
people.
Stopping that trend is big task.
The IOM only has a few projects up and running,
and a staff of just three.
"We are expanding.
You're right.
Right now we're quite small.
But the strategy in terms of decreasing the
numbers of migrants crossing the Mediterranean
to Europe is creating opportunities in their
own countries, and of course to get the message
out that it's really not worth the risk of
crossing the desert."
Musa Foon and his crew are returning after
a long day on the river.
They have little to show for it.
Today's catch will earn each of them less
than a euro.
That's not much financial security for a young
man supporting his parents.
"Sometimes I do feel stress.
I feel stress thinking I really need to help
my family.
But I cannot.
The financial support is now there.
So I feel the stress in me sometimes."
Two of Musa's siblings migrated to Europe,
and regularly send money home.
Musa himself set out twice on the journey,
but failed both times.
His father says the family couldn't survive
without money from abroad.
"We cannot avoid it.
Because of necessity.
We have a problem.
Necessity.
"Why do you think it is a necessity?"
"When they are here, they cannot keep them
up.
With the family.
So one has to quit up and find his way out,
to earn more, to support the rest."
The next morning Musa Foon's boat is back
out on the water.
He says he needs to earn 100 euros a month
to make a reasonable living.
That's still a long way away.
So like other Gambians he faces a difficult
choice -- to stick out the hardships at home,
or set out, once more, for the promise of
Europe.